the Pope's response has been tone-deaf
at best pathetic evil at worst he
literally said I will not speak an a
single word about you speak some more
words what hot speak a lot of words I
want to hear a lot of words from you
Pope Francis I'm very glad to have our
next guest we're having him back last
time him and I were disagreeing very
respectfully might I add on a convert
crowd or a weak and and and I think
today will probably be agreeing quite a
bit he's been at the forefront kind of
speaking out against really you know
corruption within within the church
period across we're been very consistent
and I wanted to get an expert's opinion
as a non Catholic outsider you can
follow him on the Twitter at Michael
underscore Voris as long as they allow
him to church militant calm mister voice
how are you sir hello Steven how are you
as long as they allow us to that's true
yes I don't think I don't think Pope
Francis will be in trouble anytime soon
with a climate change in polar bear
tweets but this interview might be
better plastic straws plastic straws in
the ocean yeah big horrible crisis the
paper straws it seems seems as though
this I'm glad that this man has his
priorities straight okay
so let me ask you this before we go
obviously this the the the sex scandal
now has been covered most people know
what's going on but a lot of people
don't really know the details
could you fill people in who don't know
exactly where where did this start the
more recent scandal I mean I know we can
go back obviously far becoming in the
church history early 2000s but what
we're talking about right now why are we
talking about this where does it stem
from the bottom line is this all sort of
came to fruition because of a series of
events really this summer it's kind of
faithful Catholics refer to it as the
summer of shame actually it doesn't
sound like a fun summer that's not a
good summer summer I sort of I'm pretty
sure that's not a Beach Boys hit but the
former Cardinal of Washington DC now
retired for Cardinal Theodore McCarrick
it was announced of about him by the New
York Archdiocese which is where he was
originally ordained as a just boldly
priest back in the 40s or 50s
a credible allegation had come forward
that he had groped an altar boy in the
rectory I'm sorry in the sacristy where
you get dressed for mass but on the
vestments of st. Patrick's Cathedral at
the time that happened the boy was 14 or
15 anyway about a year ago six months
ago
he came forward reported that nobody has
ever been able to get a hold the guy and
say why did you report this after 45
years nonetheless he reported it after
45 years the New York archdiocese
because that's where it happened
took over the case they did their
investigation at the end of their
investigation they concluded that what
he was saying was in fact credible and
at that moment the the rules of the
church kicked in and the fact that he
was a cardinal was kind of beside the
point he what he had done because it
involved a minor it doesn't matter that
was 45 years ago that had to be made
announced you know because he was a
cardinal the Pope had to be told and
then very short and what happened this
is a little more severe than potentially
drunken sex at a party 35 years ago with
tutu don't remember the place or time or
having any evidence yes it's a little
bit the root of the year right or a year
or even even the general region I don't
even know what their main mineral export
is where this happened so I do want to
make sure that you know this is that we
when you say credible because I do want
you know this obviously goes back to the
the Vigano letters kind of all stems
from this a lot of people know a little
bit about it not necessarily at under
there there's quite a bit in there for
people who haven't read it sure so it's
kind of play devil's advocate here you
just said credible so you think that
Vigano is credible you don't think that
this is just holding like a personal
grudge because there have been some
theories you know floated like that what
what determines credibility in this
instance and I'll have a follow-up to
that okay well going back to because
viado is something that comes later in
the summer what made the Theodore
McCarrick charge is credible generally
when they're looking for credibility's
they're looking for something that
substantiates what you're saying and in
a case 45 years ago what they would
generally look for is well did the 14
when
was 14 or 15 did the teenage boy tell
anybody back then are those people
around can they be questioned they
remember you sort of dig all those sorts
of things up and now while those aren't
necessarily proof they certainly lend
more credibility than then mckarrick
whose answer was I don't have any
recollection of this yeah I mean that's
that's his whole defense and the other
guy said so however they determined
these charges were credible that those
details we don't know but typically in
these kinds of cases you look for
corroborating evidence and people who
can support the story from way back when
which is of course in the case of
Cavanaugh and Ford
she has no corroborating evidence and
nobody's supporting her story except
just herself so it was not even her she
won't support her own story until
there's an FBI investigation fairly the
FBI is really they see it like I think
the DNC they see it as the Oppo research
arm look they don't realize that's not
what the FBI is for guys they actually
serve a purpose in here well I mean you
got it you got to give them some break
here Stephen that's how they used it for
eight years under Obama so you know old
habits die hard this is exactly true
well I mentioned the Vig on a letter
because that's how most people were
introduced to it because he obviously
sort of corroborated this the story with
mckarrick and he claimed that Pope
Francis knew that's where you know it
kind of goes to the top and I think
that's where where most people jump in
and have been pretty upset about it that
happened later in the summer but well
there's there's a second set of stuff
here that what Vigano is talking about
is not about the what was 45 years ago a
teenage boy in the sacristy of st.
Patrick's Cathedral
after this mckarrick sort of developed a
reputation once he became a bishop of
homosexual assaults on multiple
seminarians when he was the Bishop of
Metuchen he had the diocese Metuchen
spend Catholics money to buy a beach
house yeah high n develop that
reputation when she said that he
developed a reputation as a homosexual
there's a nasty rumor that he's a serial
homosexual assaulter okay on seminarians
yes yeah yeah it's nice all right he
we know all of this was the case because
a couple of diocese in the late - I'm
sorry in the early 2000s had to pay out
they wrote they paid out a total of 185
thousand dollars to different victims
who had been seminarians this that he
was a homosexual predator rapist of
seminarians at that beach house has been
well known by zillions of people in the
church particularly in the hierarchy for
decades and that is what vegan Oh the
former papal ambassador was referencing
in his expose saying the Pope knew about
that Pope Francis knew about that and
what do you believe that I want to make
because again I don't you know leave the
dead do I Braves me oh absolutely
okay absolutely absolutely his papal
ambassador knew if you go through sort
of the the testimony or your viewers if
they want to read it they should have
yep it's a curiosity but but in some the
reason vegan owes testimony is so very
believable okay he gets a couple of
minor things wrong I mean you see I was
working at you know a date is off by a
month here there that sort of thing but
you know the thrust of it is that this
became known that Pope Benedict stepped
in and after McCarrick had already
retired and said you know I want him to
stop traveling around and being out
there he just needs to sort of her quiet
you know quietly retired to a life of
prayer and penance he's gonna be dead
soon so you know just you know for the
sake of scandal just you know we don't
need to make all this public just retire
mop the scene and there was a big blowup
in the in the nunciature the the
ambassador's house the Vatican
Ambassador house in Washington DC
because the Vatican ambassador called
mckarrick in and told him this Pope
Benedict wants you quietly off the scene
and this huge argument blew why quietly
by the way this is one thing that does
by and as an as a non Catholic observer
let me kind of explain this to you why
to me this is my chart of you I went to
I've been to several of the different
churches and I've moved around so I've
had to attend different churches there
was one Church where a man an assistant
pastor
wasn't sexual abuse of a child or
anything but had an affair they kept it
in the dark and the guy moved on he left
no one knew why he was preaching in a
church down the road there was another
Church where similar thing happened
where I attended they actually called in
all of the elders and anyone who was a
member of that church they were as
transparent as possible moved him out
even though he helped helped plant that
church and moved on on the trail you can
guess where one pastor was able to
continue preaching the other one not
ever again so why and why I'm quiet I
don't understand this approach here at
all well this this secrecy or a privacy
thing is what really sort of you know
has a good number good percentage of
faithful Catholics kind of upset for the
same reason you just said I guess in
some cases there is a there is a
principle I suppose you could call it a
principle in canon law the law which
sort of governs the operation of the
church and share the sacraments that
somebody has a right to their good name
that you don't even if something even if
something is true if you don't need to
say it about somebody then don't
so in some cases how you apply this
depends for example the Pope just
removed the bishop of the week after he
retired just removed him accepted his
resignation and it became known from the
Vatican that the Bishop of Bishop
Bransfield of Wheeling West Virginia
Charleston Wheeling West Virginia had
had in some they didn't give the details
of what it was but it was inappropriate
sexual contact with an adult they and
say if it was a male or female everybody
thinks it's a male so they know why why
does that one this is of course what is
it always male is it is there an
authority problem or is there a Zehra is
there like a you know no cash or chicks
ever so there's a there's a gay problem
at the top of the church well now you
come into this now you come into a
historical question that's a very good
question because if you go and you look
at sexual predation abuse both of minors
and of adults so you know you've got the
you know somebody you know a guy you
know molest softball coach
molesting you know teenage players on
his team versus Harvey Weinstein so
right it's sexual molestation one's a
crime the other is also a crime but this
is like the more disgusting crime yeah
out in the world that is generally 85%
heterosexual heterosexual males
attacking you know the opposite sex
whether it's girls or women right in the
church with the clergy it's just the
opposite and the reason is because such
a large percentage of the Catholic
clergy are homosexual now we've been
reporting this for years I know you and
I have been we have been blasted by
every official Church everything our own
bishop here in Detroit will have nothing
to do with us told us to take the name
Catholic out although I didn't have a
right to do that but that side story
told us take the name Catholic research
on him call the FBI have him run an
investigation
I bet you'll find some interesting
tidbits there yeah I know I know you've
been at the front of this I don't
understand what why is why if the if the
goal here is to actually preserve sort
of the purity of the Catholic Church I
don't understand the secrecy I don't
understand the silencing of people like
yourself how that helps I understand it
from a PR perspective but I can't
understand it from a from a theological
from a spiritual perspective at this
point
yeah because well I it's just it's just
become known at this point you just kind
of another just series of just you know
gross vomitus stuff coming out again
and you know I've said it before
publicly I'll say it here on your show
there are a large number I don't know
what I don't know what's how to put a
percentage on it but there is a large
large number of Catholic clergy
including Cardinals Cardinals bishops
priests deacons people who run
seminaries a little bit who hide behind
the fact they are clerics or clergy in
the church but who do not believe the
faith
these are Judas's and you know there's a
saint who I believe it was Saint Agustin
but I might be mistaken on who it was
but there's a saint who said in answer
to the question why would our law
have picked judas iscariot knowing that
he was going to betray him long as he
knew he's gonna betray him because he
was God yeah was and that was kind of a
giveaway see it started back it started
back then Jesus like yeah what's okay I
know what's happening but did you have
to do it that you could have just you
know said him alright sorry I can do I
think it was saying us and whichever
saying it was said the reason one of the
reasons that he did that was to
demonstrate that even in the very close
circle of his own intimates those
apostles that even their one could
betray him so and and lead to his death
I mean what did what did Judas
ultimately do I mean he committed
suicide out of despair but the lead up
to that was that he was part and parcel
of deicide he helped plan and execute
the the the death of God so if that
could happen and you're right in direct
contact with Jesus himself we wake up
every morning hello Jesus good morning
I'll go cook your fish for you if you
could do job no fire Wow any of these
other bishops could do the very same
thing and the Catholic Church has been
you know if you sort of look at those
are the 2,000 year history of it it
really starts to kind of fall apart or
breakdown along the lines of very good
holy wonderful magnificent Saints and
kind of the opposite extreme of the
spectrum these horrible vicious
diabolical almost possessed in their
mind and heart haters of the faith who
also happen to be priests and I think
it's important to note he's an outlier
there and in this case at what point
does the rule does the exception become
the rule when you toss for example a
disproportionate amount of it being
homosexual assault I mean I think what
is it half a billion dollars if I'm not
mistaken or over a billion dollars have
been paid out to think the total payouts
for all of the sexual assault but not
all of the sexual assault was almost
sexual but the vast majority of it was
but the the price tag right now is very
close to four billion dollars CI and
and I was way off I was trying to take
the most conservative estimate that I
could find but I appreciate that the
Catholics giving me more leeway on this
and being transparent about it I mean
again it the question becomes at what
point is the exception now the rule and
and why do you think again why do you
think so disproportionately in the
church the the homosexual abuse again to
an outsider and to an outsider
the Pope's response has been tone-deaf
at best pathetic
evil at worse in a sense that for the
only thing we're evil to prevail we know
is for good men to do nothing so in this
case he literally said I will not speak
in a single word about you speak some
more words one-hot speaking a lot of
words I want to hear a lot of words from
you Pope Francis that's what I want to
hear right now as many words as humanly
possible how about that because that's
the ones kid out there the question
becomes why and what do people like you
you know true faith following Catholics
what can you do about it okay that's a
bunch of question I know okay the first
is why the disproportionate amount well
the disproportionate amount is directly
related to the disproportionate amount
of homosexual abuse be it to minors or
seminarians and adults you know non
minors is owing directly to the larger
proportion of homosexual men in the
Catholic priesthood there's just more of
a percentage of homosexual men in the
Catholic priesthood so the question is
okay how did that get to be the case
right and lots of research has shown
that back in the 1920s and early 1930s
particularly here in the United States
around the world but particularly here
in the United States Joseph Stalin you
know our lovely you know Uncle Joe and
you know communist Russia Athens nobody
he's never killed anybody that's right
those show trials were not show trials
they were actually real things religion
is the cause of all [ __ ] yes continue
that's correct
he wanted the he had made quite clear
that he wanted the destruction of the
Catholic Church and set about to do it
and one of the orders he gave that was
picked up on by a woman here in the
United States who was in the Communist
Party here in the United States that her
name was Bella Dodd she placed roughly
her own you know testimony that she
placed roughly 11
and I'm sorry Stalin had said make sure
you put in smart guys these are
communist agents make sure you put in
get into Catholic seminaries smart guys
who are able to pass themselves off as
being very Orthodox very Catholic and
the whole bit and everything but who are
homosexual so she set out and over the
course of I think it was exactly 12 13
14 years she recruited roughly eleven
hundred men who fit that bill and got
them into seminaries and as you you know
now because that's a while ago on you
know they clearly these homosexuals
don't breed so how does is it just they
have like their apprentices or they they
then appoint yeah a successor their
their understanding of going in was to
sort of you know lay the dynamite for
the destruction of the church okay
so they made sure that they made sure
that they were whenever they needed to
be networked they were networked with
each other they made you know and look
at they're going to excel 1100 guys some
are going to excel up the ranks so
there's going to be kind of lonely lowly
whatever and just sort of hang out and
the you know and the you know the back
waters and I mean you know Liberace you
guys have a lot of gold there's a lot of
pomp and circumstance it's attractive
its attractive to the gig I don't blame
them for that this fashion sense matches
up that's not a bad thing yep you
haven't been in a Catholic Church in a
while how do you see because that's not
what it looks like now well it's great
the Catholic Church is a great beautiful
hotel about the Vatican would people you
know if they watched it on TV like oh
man I've to be a part of that you know
it's like going to a Liberace in his
prime but okay so here's I guess my
question because I don't have a ton of
time so we go back and I would like
people to do research and read some of
your material on kind of a history of
the Catholic Church and installing this
sort of infiltration that you've I know
you've written about quite a bit you
just mentioned sort of the
investigations now how do you think
considering that the church has been
infiltrated for lack of a better word
and we don't really know
no one knows whether it's a majority and
minority or to what extent how should
the investigations be conducted because
this is where faith in the institution
erodes it which
conducted internally by people at the
church who you know have been basically
planted in by Stalin because they want
to wear epaulets that's that's a good
sum up yeah well remember now that the
the folks who are problematic now
probably aren't officially communist
agents they probably are not but they
were influenced by that these were the
ones who were picked to come into
seminary
while other guys were blocked out of
seminary right and then you had the 19
like college professors most of them
probably aren't actively but you know
listen the good good one got blocked out
and we end up with you know UT Arlington
so well that's exactly Truman there are
a lot of parallels yeah there are a lot
of parallels me if you're talking about
communism talk about communism and
socialism is sort of world domination
thing and these you know this clash of
world ideologies well I mean we as an
American government we mean we tried to
destabilize communist governments all
over the world and we did and you know
all of that so I mean of course the
other side is doing that right and if
they're trying to destabilize Western
civilization which is exactly what
communism was trying to do and in some
ways still is trying to do well of
course you go after one of the you know
the the the establisher of Western
civilization which was the Catholic
Church yeah what up holds it him if you
read the you know a writer the the head
of the Italian Communist Party in the
1920s and 30s Antonio Gramsci he says
comes right out and says the Catholic
Church has to be destroyed we cannot
take over the culture until the upholder
of the culture the Catholic Church is
wiped out though you know they should do
they should hire a really bad proof
writer for Joel Osteen's books and just
feather it man they're how do you how do
you think these investigations should be
conducted both both what is deal what is
theological e what is morally correct
and what do you think would be the best
way to go about it to to rekindle faith
in the institutions right now that I
know for a lot of Catholics has but it
has been pretty tough how should these
investigations go well the investigation
depends on you know what level is the
investigation happening on is it
happening on the level of the universal
Church and we're going to invest this
one board
is it going to happen you know country
by country there is a lot of desire on
the part of a good number of Bishops the
United States to investigate on a number
of different levels number one the
question is how did mckarrick rise to
that level that he rose to cos he was
probably the senior most powerful
Cardinal in the church sure you you
might even say in all of American
history the history of the church in
America if that's a little bit of an
overstatement it is just a little bit of
an overstatement he had great influence
people suggesting Cardinals to be named
and you know he got Cardinal soup pitch
in Cardinal Tobin Cardinal superchips
Chicago and Joseph Tobin of Newark named
by whispering into Pope Francis's ear
those two guys are the most soup it's to
remind your audience is the guy who said
we're not going to go down this rabbit
hole of this you know we have to worry
about things like the environment we're
not going to worry about you know clergy
sex abuse stuff right yeah that's the
guy that got picked by Pope Francis
because mckarrick is whispering in his
ear maybe on the rabbit hole yeah so
people want to know
yeah and bishops want to know how did
this guy get up to this power you're not
taking seminarians by the truckload you
know every other weekend your beach
house in New Jersey raping them all
nobody knows about it so how did this
happen
yeah what was interesting as soon as
that revelation came out not not the kid
in New York revelation but that was one
thing that's what made it public and
gave us all the ability to now begin
talking about the adult you know sexual
assaults on the seminarians
and when all of that started coming out
and being freely talked about the other
thing was just the trigger for that this
is this is really the heart of the
matter and loads of bishops and priests
and everything they're saying how did
this guy get through who supported of
course all the Cardinals Cardinal Sean
O'Malley in Boston Donald Wuerl in
Washington DC I mean just go down the
list tick tick tick tick and they're all
like well I never heard anything about
this I never
that's ridiculous they're lying through
their teeth and never there's the man
who now named Sean O'Malley from Boston
would actually be considered too
stereotypical in a jughead cartoons
where no one would buy it so okay so
should there be a Sean O'Malley yeah
Ozzy Anderson a whether they want to
they want to know is how did McAra cry
so who knew why who knew what and when
did they know it the second thing is
Archbishop vegan owes vegan owes
testimony it's 11 pages long well I tell
you it names names it names names it
even there - sorry chili says who were
there that's a more of a kind of
universal Church thing that's not
there's a lot of things in that
testimony that pertains specifically to
the church in America which can sort of
piecemeal be investigated and looked
into and stuff but his stuff because of
the what he was he was essentially the
ambassador for me not essentially he was
the ambassador
the Pope's ambassador first Benedict's
for a couple of years and then Pope
Francis he continued on after I just I
don't want to get too cuz again keep in
mind most people watching you're not
Catholic and he said we're talking about
you know vegan oh he said the Pope's
full of it
so who investigates the Pope that's good
question God right
but who investigates the Pope you know
for any actual criminal act because it's
criminal if there's if there's cover of
it's criminal if there's complicit
if he's complicit with this if he's I
was here you run it here you run into
all sorts of you know kind of
international yeah he's you know he's
got a number of different hats one of
them is he's a he's the you know the
sovereign head of a sovereign state so
who would do that I can tell you this I
tell you one thing they are
extraordinarily concerned about at the
Vatican not necessarily because they
come and arrest the Pope and put them on
trial or something exactly I don't know
who has the who internationally has the
authority to come and arrest any leader
of a country and put him on trial for
anything right I mean you know nobody
can come and arrest Donald Trump they
should have arrested Obama and put him
on trial for being stupid and liberal
and socialist but I mean who would do
that but but the plan is though with
with Donald Trump you know obviously you
see with with Bill President Bill
Clinton someone can be impeached it's
not only people he's appointed it
effectively not a government that he's
created investigating him that is the
difference I think with the Pope and
that is that is the problems we'll run
into there are more checks and balances
against a president here than the Pope
you're right he does wear a lot of
different hats
also he wears a lot of different hats he
wears them and he does wear along two
different hats
no but I mean look he's this he's that
he's the if my if my political history
sir
me correctly he's the last remaining
monarch in Europe so nobody I mean the
way you got rid of Kings before was to
assassinate them I don't think anybody's
saying let's assassinate the Pope no
let's be clear no one here however there
are more there are different ways to
skin a cat and I can tell you from
sources we have in Rome that people in
the Vatican are horrified at the
prospect of a Rico investigation again
not because that leads back to the
Vatican and then they're able to like
you know slap cufflinks on or you know
slap them with cuffs and draw all them
out to trial I'm sure he got but he does
get cuff links left on quite a bit again
stylish stylish guy they have lots of
very nice cufflinks you'll notice we
don't make enough money here to wear
cufflinks I have a button-down polo
shirt well it suits you so there might
be something going on but here's kind of
the question that obviously as a
non-catholic as someone who who loves
all all Catholics with non Catholic
Christians period right but the issue is
the theological think a lot of people
look at and go ok we understand that
obviously this Pope most Catholics
believe that when he speaks you know ex
cathedra we're talking about
theologically he's correct but at this
point which thank God he hasn't done
like Chauncey Gardiner you know you
don't know what's gonna come out of that
mouth at this point right now is
tweeting about polar bears and climate
change I will not say a word shut up
you're saying nothing but words just not
the one who's that matter at this point
I am what is it all worth this is a
system this is the way the church is set
up and like even if it can be
infiltrated but at this point you have a
guy at the top who clear either doesn't
care or is complicit and it seems like
there's no way to take him out so it
seems like once you get past kind of
minutia and we can get really nerdy
theologically obviously there's people
who study it but most people who don't I
can understand what a lot of people are
having a bit of a crisis in faith
because this is kind of the rule of law
as you kind of describe for the Catholic
the church the Vatican and it seems
broken yeah well if look if when any
system that you have you know a
hypothetically bad actor in you know who
has some authority and as you move up in
your hypothetical situation here a lot
of authority things
go bad there's no such thing as a
perfect system but here's what we do
know is that the Catholic Church the
governance of the Catholic Church was
instituted by Christ himself he picked a
bunch of guys that were kind of not sort
of the best dudes around one of them
betrayed him the other 11 ran away the
hit the guy he picked to be the head of
the of his little first band of apostles
there
betrayed him three times well you know
denounced him three times swearing and
cursing and blaspheming him and
everything else so you know this is not
the fact that there are human beings who
have been given governance of the church
doesn't mean and who sometimes are bad
yeah has a history of many people were
bad like I said it seems the way it kind
of cuts is you get these people over
here who were great Saints and wonderful
holy people and then you have the other
side over here kind of on the far
extreme there doesn't seem to be an
awful lot of people in the Middle clear
I agree I'm not saying that every single
person obviously I know that about the
funny I'm just trying to paint the kind
of the bounds like rice before the
rooster crowed no he didn't rape a kid
let's let's keep this clear like I don't
you know Peter made some mistakes but he
didn't quite go over the bend that you
know not around the bend that far well I
think what really bothers people that
seemed a lot of people we have a lot of
Catholic viewers who obviously have have
felt in the past that there's been a
media witch-hunt this is something it's
and we do have to get going here pretty
soon but I could talk about this for a
long time and I appreciate you taking
the time a lot of Catholics in the past
who felt that this was a media
witch-hunt and in many cases were
correct not always but in this case
they're really tired of it they feel
hopeless because like you said well what
do we do with the Pope I guess let God
deal with them they don't feel as though
there's much they can do but what is
striking to me is that in this case
where you have more Catholics as if I'm
just going by the temperature of the
audience here who seemed upset with it
but the media is not covering it nearly
as much as when you okay because it's
gay you know it's it's it's a striking
flip here and I don't think it's
necessarily just the gay thing but it's
also because this is kind of the liberal
piece of Bernie Sanders Pope oh yeah
absolutely look you're not gonna go out
if you go back and look at any of the
media
Reports most of the media reports even
the movie spotlight which overall did a
good job sort of presenting the little
Boston exposure of all the child
sex-abuse stuff and everything back in
2002 won an Academy Award - what I
thought it was very good I'm glad to
hear you say that because I thought it
was very tasty I made it mandatory
viewing for the staff here we did I
think we took would 1520 people to go
see it and everybody who didn't see it I
had to go see it separately on their own
so yeah there were but if you notice in
the movie the way the movie presented it
was the guy who was Richard Sipe man
just died who done a lot of the thing
the voice Oh a voice on the phone comes
right out and says well this isn't a
homosexual thing and it is a homosexual
thing so the media the secular
mainstream media went out of their way
to downplay much like whenever you know
Muhammad Obama Muhammad a bomb it blows
up something they say a a foreign
student and they refuse to mention the
fact that he's Muslim yeah well that
same thing was going on here with the
treatment of homosexual clergy right
we're the ones doing the abuse and and
now this time around again what has
really come out that's why I kind of
draw that distinction earlier we were
talking between minors and adults is
that you know however people might see
you know boys being attacked sexually
and things like that you know they could
say oh well maybe the guys just crazy
he's just psychologically immature or
he'll just go after altar boys because
they're easier to get to but when you're
talking about an adult male who's you
know in his 30s or 40s going after a you
know a 20 year old a 24 year old
seminarian that's gay
yeah that's gay and that's gay and with
the end of the day still yeah and so
they don't know Chaldees anymore it's
just it's just gay and and that's gay
it's gay as we call it around here or we
write in our strips homosexual predation
on young men that's what it has been
it's always been that some of these guys
some also sometimes one over got younger
boys right but this has always been
going on not always I don't mean back to
the
time of the Apostles means of this
recent 5060 years right this has been a
very very prominent thing this is able
to be ignored
by folks in the church because these
people never really come forward and say
anything they are now thank God right
and also it's not something the media
cares about because it undermines their
whole narrative about Oh gay is great
and this is wonderful let's have pride
flags and oh this is an alternative
lifestyle you know no the predominance
of sexual abuse within the homosexual
world is ten times greater than it is in
the heterosexual world let me ask you
this final question before we go would
you say it's worse now than it's ever
been in the history of the Catholic
Church as far as crisis as yeah and as
far as sexual abuse and misconduct
i it's hard to say it's with regard
specifically to sexual abuse and
misconduct I mean yeah you know first of
all this is all out in the open now
thanks to social media and this that and
everything that's one - there's just
more Catholics now than there's ever
been so I don't know if there's sort of
a proportionality thing going on there
what I will say is that overall the
state of the church in the West
meaning Western or the english-speaking
world the West Europe and the rest of
the english-speaking world you know
England America Australia etc
Philippines has never been in a more
sorry state okay and I would lay 90% of
the blame for that right at the feet of
the bishops going back to the early part
of the 20th century who allowed this
this homosexual infiltration into the
church didn't check it some of them
became involved in it and it just began
to snowball and that's what we're seeing
right what you're seeing here is the
fruits of evil well I appreciate you
disclosing that I appreciate being so
transparent and I and I appreciate the
answer the reason I ask is because it
seems that there's an inverse
relationship between when the media says
this is going to fix the Catholic Church
Pope Francis is going to come in and fix
the situation he's the best Pope we've
had he's the cool Pope he's the of the
people pub for people who really care
about the church seems like your
antennas should go up because and that's
why I wanted a catholics perspective I
do see it right now as as as in crisis
and and obviously what's most important
is is solving the situation to make sure
there are no more victims going forward
that's that's my number one priority I
think it's not everyone's number one
priority who's a Christian concerned
with with the catholic church or any
Church at this point alright that is
Michael underscore Voris on twitter as
long as they allow you search militant
calm yes final word sir I would say look
every time the church has been in a
crisis before its 2000 years lots of
crises some isolated some universal the
answer is now what the answer has always
been which is be a good Catholic live
your faith like you are supposed to live
it which is to with an eye to getting to
heaven you sin you sin you go to
confession do whatever live a holy life
that's the point get to heaven all that
and things will work out also vote
McCarrick speech house that is Michael
Voris thank you very much sir
hey there YouTube viewer if you like
this video I would say subscribe hit the
notification bell or watch one of these
videos playing in a box that we've
personally uploaded in program for your
viewing pleasure the problem is now in
today's day and age on YouTube in 2018
any of those three things that you do
any of those three buttons that you
click will take you directly to a Seth
Meyers video so stay here and join monk
get off of here go to a lot of credit
come /mo club it's the only safe place
you can go enjoy